vanessa bryant just took her fam on a
dreamy trip abroad
and her instagram is like the official
how-to guide for crushing a european
vacation
the proud mama has been documenting her
summer getaway with her daughter's
18 year old natalia four-year-old bianca
and two-year-old capri
on social media starting with a stop in
croatia where they visited the filming
location of the fictional city of king's
landing from the show
game of thrones vanessa posted several
snaps from the destination
writing on instagram that her late
husband kobe bryant
had given their daughter natalia the
green light to go on a trip to croatia
with her class her senior year of high
school but the trip was cancelled due to
the pandemic
she added quote i wanted to make sure
that natalia got the opportunity to
visit
it's beautiful the bryant ladies were
also joined by their friend
kat gasol who's married to kobe's
longtime teammate and friend
pau gasol the gals posed it up for some
cute
bestie selfies and after their excursion
it was nothing but fun in the sun
vanessa posted this nap
relaxing on a yacht paddle boarding and
swimming in the water
the 39 year old and her gal pal ate
meals by the water with their kiddos
before heading off to san tropez
i love you
[Music]
goku are you dancing where it was a
straight up
dance party at the table
[Music]
goku are you dancing
the ladies posed for lots and lots
and lots of cute selfies then they were
off to can where it was nothing but
jacuzzis on yachts
more epic selfies yachts
jet skiing out on the water
more jacuzzis on yachts tubing did i
mention
yachts and playing in water fountains
of course this latest vacation comes
after vanessa jetted off to jamaica with
her girls and
kobe's side of the family in june at the
time the widow of the late nba star
shared pics from her
tropical getaway with her kids and
extended family
in one snap vanessa and her girls posed
with kobe's sister and brother-in-law
sharya and jared washington along with
their kids
the caption family she went on to post a
second group shot from their vacation
which she captioned with red heart
emojis
but get this the trip was a surprise
sharia praised her sister-in-law for
putting the whole thing together
writing on instagram quote i'm not sure
how she does it
but vanessa bryant pulled off another
huge surprise
family trip to jamaica absolutely
[Music]
amazing
you